the jurgen experience like when you do
stand up the people who are in the
audience have a [ __ ] vote on my act
like they actually have a direct
influence i give a giant [ __ ] about them
they paid money and they came they
[ __ ] traveled parked a car got a
babysitter and they're sitting shoulder
to shoulder with strangers listening so
if i see a face that goes huh i [ __ ]
see it and it may not change my joke
entirely but it there's a there's a
gland in me
that takes all of that in and you know
what i mean in the aggregate
and changes and it's not about their
acceptance sometimes it's about going to
what upsets them and pushing past it but
they're involved and i'm i have to keep
that clean that it's about me and them
yeah if i read something by somebody who
didn't come to the show who doesn't go
to comedy shows who's reacting to
something that was written about a show
a person who wrote it to get
clicks somebody who's professionally
disgruntled and says this was a bad show
and then somebody tweets yeah [ __ ] that
guy and i'm letting that person
outweigh the rights of my audience it's
irresponsible so i don't even think you
should it's not about reading it and
then resisting it you shouldn't even be
aware of it you should just stay [ __ ]
those people if they're not there right
they're not involved i couldn't agree
more and i think that it's also
it'll change the way you do comedy if
you take that if you internalize that
yeah if you're picturing the jokes
you're telling to this audience going
out into the world and what are they
going to say about it and again in a
world that it's a sport to get upset
yeah it's a it's a soothing fun sport
and i have no problem with it they can
play that game together and that's fine
but if you let it actually change if you
actually take it in right it's it's not
you know and they don't mean it none of
these people mean it it's just a
momentary yeah [ __ ] him and then they
move on to something else it's not
they're not invested in it you said
something to me once that i tell people
all the time you said that twitter's
just talk but it's written down so it
like seems like it's more than just talk
because people always talk like that's
right that [ __ ] sucked or oh he's a
piece of [ __ ] that's right they say
things like that normally it's normal
but you're not aware of it that's right
it's a normal thing it's even healthy
yeah as talk this is something my
ex-girlfriend who's very close to me
still blanche guarded she's a french
comedian
and she's very big in france she's huge
there and she had a bit that i can't
remember is in french and i know you
know about
that twitter that there used to be talk
and talk is air it goes out people say
that guy [ __ ] sucks just to each
other right and it's gone they don't
have to mean it you know but then it's
committed to the library of congress
and the person who can't even the person
who wrote it can't even take it back
right they're like i gotta stand behind
that now and then they gotta double down
on it and
as comedians and entertainers we're
supposed to have these people just
yapping about us yeah [ __ ] joe rogan
somebody who's even a fan yeah might
just just to enjoy his beer for the
moment right [ __ ] him yeah but then if
you showed up there you'd be like oh my
gosh
i [ __ ] love it but the fact that
comedians
comedians are partly responsible because
they're on twitter
and they want to be liked there too yeah
they want to be there overseeing the
conversations looking for somebody
saying something bad about them and then
responding are you [ __ ] high it's
crazy it's turning it's kind of
conflated things i think twitter it's
made it's and it's not i don't think
that anybody on twitter means anything
they say i don't believe that any i
don't think a single tweet is really
sincere it's just a calculation of
what's this gonna do
and it's based in fear and hope which
are both dumb things
but it's not really like a sincere this
how i feel right so if you give it all
that you know and comedians that tweet
jokes
the same exact format and type and then
tweet a political opinion in the same
thing
that's one of the reasons i think folks
have started to take jokes seriously
because there are comedians that want to
be funny and taken seriously so they're
doing both so of course people are
confused by it and there's no and it's
not in a club or at least a theater
where it's like where comedy is this
really really fun experiment
just for this one night we're not going
to worry about offending each other
we're not gonna worry about what's right
or wrong we're just gonna talk [ __ ] yeah
and we're gonna go on i'm really good at
it i can talk [ __ ] like you wouldn't
believe i'm gonna astonish you with how
much i shouldn't be saying this right
that's the game
but if you translated it to
text and put it out like a statement
like it's a [ __ ] statement right
senator yeah it's just not gonna other
people aren't gonna take it right